sometimes it feels like a game's
mechanics are made for you opens up the
plant potential watch can he drop down
hits exist up close and it's kept right
versus kenny what a tantalizing 1v1
spotted up oh
that is unbelievable other times a game
is so alluring that you can't help but
fall in love with it dude i love this
game so much man
but in the case of it's timmy
it was never about which game he played
dude i'm i'm energy too
[Applause]
it was about challenging himself to be
the best he could be
[Music]
oh
[Music]
timothy it's timion's introduction to
gaming came at a very young age at just
five years old his brother showed him
maplestory a staple rpg for anyone
growing up in the 2000s and eventually
timmy stumbled upon his first fps
soldierfront 2 but soldierfront wasn't
really able to hold timmy's attention
for too long he played it casually as a
kid but as he got older he moved on to
league of legends which would become the
first game he ever took seriously and in
august of 2017 after taking inspiration
from content creators like shroud timmy
decided that streaming could be a more
productive avenue than just gaming alone
i don't think i actually streamed i
guess like seriously until after i
graduated high school so anything before
2018 was just all for fun uh a bunch of
my friends we were just like yeah you
know let's let's just stream for fun see
how it is and we were there to go live
to just each other you know because like
obviously nobody's really gonna find you
at the very bottom when you have one
viewer timmy was good at whatever game
he picked up but it was cs go where he
was able to discover and develop his
true talent in the world of first-person
shooters unfortunately there would be
consequences for timmy's new dedication
as he found it difficult to balance
school work and gaming ever since he was
a kid timmy found it hard to sit still
and concentrate in class and things did
not improve in college he spent most of
his extra time either streaming or
watching streams it came to a point
where he was even failing some of his
classes that's when he sat down with his
parents and made a decision that would
change the course of his life they
actually didn't really come up with like
a speech or anything i just kind of
winged it and i was like hey i really
want to pursue gaming i know that's
obviously not the thing that you want to
hear but i just want to drop out of
school and i think it was the most
scariest thing to say to my parents
because i know that my dad's always like
you gotta be like this this like doctor
you gotta go to school get a good
education be like a software engineer
like your cousins so i felt like very
pressured to follow that path of like my
older siblings and older like cousins it
was a decision that could not be made
lightly and timmy knew that out of
respect for his parents he dedicated
himself to finding success as a streamer
for over a year timmy was playing league
of legends and flavor of the month
battle royales to only a handful of
people but eventually all that hard work
paid off not in the form of viewers but
a new opportunity a game that would grab
a hold of timmy and never let go
game over thanks for playing
high five when apex legends first
dropped in february of 2019 the game was
a sensation servers hit over two and a
half million players within the first 24
hours and the game became even more
popular as seasons started to roll out
but timmy wasn't playing apex due to its
popularity he was playing it because it
was genuinely a good game apex was fresh
fast and the skill ceiling was limitless
timmy had finally found a game that
matched his energy apex was a game that
i felt like i could just be super good
at but it also gave me opportunities to
do my memes you know like apex gave you
that like couple of seconds where you
had time to make content and slowly but
surely timmy's dedication and incredible
in-game mechanics attracted a small
community of viewers
oh my [ __ ] god what a shot dude i'm
i'm i'm energy too
[Applause]
but there was also something else that
made timmy stand out his sense of humor
timmy never dared to take himself too
seriously and his content was filled
with plenty of memes to complement his
highlights
on top of that timmy knew that getting
popular on twitch was a game of its own
he cooked up a brand of zoomer oriented
content that was both addictive and
entertaining and in the current age of
clicks and chaotic social media
sometimes all it takes is one clip to
make you famous
[Music]
i guess i can sell it i can sell that i
can sell it i can sell it until my
capital comes up
[Laughter]
after that one clip started to gather
buzz things changed for timmy's stream
not only did more apex fans take notice
but pros did as well one of apex's
biggest names asu started to notice
timmy's popularity as a result the two
connected and asu would even host some
of timmy's streams i think when it comes
to me and ace you know and our
friendship and how we treat each other i
mean i always look up to brandon and i
think he is just an amazing guy amazing
content creator i want to say he was
like by far one of the the biggest helps
in my career for sure from that moment
on timmy's twitch career skyrocketed his
viewership had gone from single digits
to the thousands in just a few short
years the newfound friendships with
people he looked up to was something out
of a dream the success he was finding
with his audience was better than he
could ever have imagined but for timmy
it wasn't enough he had made a
commitment to his parents to be the best
version of himself and if he was going
to be a professional gamer he was going
to be the greatest in the world and in
order to do that timmy started setting
challenges for himself
insane goals to reach to prove that he
was worthy of his growing audience the
first challenge he set for himself was
to hit 10 000 damage in a single apex
match and although he fell just short
that match was a sight to behold
no i could have gotten the 10k man i
really could have i could have gotten a
10k this game i'm trolling
of trolling oh if i shot the i should
have shut the down guys over the course
of the next year timmy's stream
continued to grow he even got picked up
by loaded the same agency that
represented shroud but by march of 2021
timmy had basked in the glow of his
success for long enough
it was time for another challenge timmy
attempted to go from bronze to master in
one stream and over 33 hours later
he did it
[Applause]
i'm not talking about just so we only
need one
but since this is timmy we're talking
about he needed to up the ante so late
in april timmy went on a journey to go
from bronze to apex predator in one
stream that's apex's highest rank and he
was going to achieve it without sleeping
the day is going to be a
banger stream but it's going to be a
long and painful one as well
this had never been done before and
timmy would not just be putting his
skill to the test but his body and mind
as well and there were times where timmy
didn't think he could do it at all
all we just need two wins
or
three second places
or
death
the holy [ __ ] i don't know if i have
enough in me but against all odds timmy
hit apex predator in 54 hours and in
front of over 135
000 people
[Music]
timmy had done what no one else had
dared to do and for better or for worse
in regards to his health he discovered
that grinding without sleep was another
hidden skill of his on top of that
there'd been another game taking up time
on his channel valrant apex was still
his main game but it was impossible to
ignore valorent's popularity and once he
sunk his teeth into it timmy quickly
proved that his tack fps skills were
still up to snuff and his ability to
make viral clips was not bound to any
one game
timmy was having a blast playing
ballarat so just a few months after
finishing the apex predator challenge he
decided that it was time to do the same
thing invalorant going from bronze to
radiant in one stream
[Music]
oh my god
[Music]
yes serious sir
[Music]
yes sir
unfortunately though timmy was on the
cusp of reaching radiant he needed to
end his stream for his own safety i
would love to continue
but as i am getting towards day three
of staying awake day three is where it
gets really bad and it actually could
get dangerous right but timmy's
three-day bender would not be in vain as
a direct result of timmy's grinding and
decimated sleep schedule he netted
millions of viewers over the course of
both challenges and over 100 000 new
followers timmy had done it he
essentially mastered two of the most
popular shooters in the world and there
was nothing stopping him from going even
further and grinding other games so in
april of 2022 timmy took on his biggest
challenge a subathon he ended up
streaming for 29 days straight taking
fans with him through all the madness
sleeping and of course hall of fame
level clips
two more
[Music]
[Music]
oh my god
right
for his efforts timmy reached 59 000
subscribers on twitch and was able to
take a much needed break to spend time
with family and friends who knows what
challenge is next for timmy for the sake
of his health he might not want to
become known as the challenge guy i feel
like yeah i should try to do things that
are a little bit realistic and that
won't you know hopefully be 60 hours
every single time i think a challenge
that's you know still 24 hours is still
a great challenge as long as it's hard
to do i do want to say that my health is
probably decaying as as i do i do those
challenges and i have to be very careful
but when it comes to what's possible for
timmy anything is on the table for me it
was just like i want to set myself all
the way
up here and like i want to be i want to
be doing these challenges that are just
like no one else can do or no one ever
thought of it's timmy is one of the best
case studies in streaming for hard work
and dedication like plenty of other kids
who grew up on the internet the
conventional life path just wasn't meant
for him now he gets to indulge in his
success by being flown around by his
sponsor red bull or playing apex with
post malone and above all else timmy is
still humble despite all his hard work
the things he gave up and the literal
sleepless nights
he still thanks the people around him
for his success i want to thank
everybody uh like my parents my family
my friends and especially my girlfriend
aileen for always supporting me you know
throughout everything uh i do really
appreciate everybody uh my community i
appreciate you guys as well thank you
guys for supporting me always throughout
every game whether it's apex valorento
or any fps i do appreciate you guys a
lot and uh yeah thank you guys again
appreciate it
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this hit the sub button and
ring the notification bell for unique
bite size videos you won't find anywhere
else hit us up on our twitter instagram
facebook and tech talk
[Music]